everybody is figuring out how do I
comply with this new federal rule rule
not how do I provide care better faster
and cheaper hi i'm nick gillespie with
reason TV and we're at freedom fest and
we're talking to grace marie turner
president of the gallon institute and
author of why obamacare is wrong for
America recent book about health care
thanks grace marie thank you nice to be
with you what is the what's the worst
likely outcome of Obamacare we lose our
freedom I mean this is this is really I
think the front and the battle for
freedom because if we lose the ability
to make decisions about the health care
we're going to get I mean this could be
life or death decisions that have been
turned over to Washington bureaucrats to
Washington politicians taking them away
from doctors and patients give us an
example of how a new part of part of the
health care reform bill actually takes
more things away from it well I think
the individual mandate that the
government telling us for the first time
that we have to spend our own personal
running to purchase health insurance at
it defines it is likely to be the first
or second most expensive item and family
budgets twenty thousand dollars a year
the federal government is telling us we
have to purchase this under penalty of
law how do you rebut the idea that
looked they are you know these people if
they're not buying insurance they're
just costing a lot of money they should
be doing it anyway the difference is
that whether or not the federal
government tells us we have to buy this
extensive health insurance policy that
it defines rather than allowing us to
make the choice of whether or not we
want to pay through a health savings
account whether they want to pay out of
our pocket to have the federal
government tell us we have to buy this
comprehensive insurance policy it's a
very different thing than allowing us to
make the decisions about how we pay for
a minute and it makes it even where I
mean government is at all levels is
already spending fifty cents of every
healthcare dollar anyway so this
it'sit's that's bad enough and then this
just extends it evening well and
basically the cost of uncompensated care
which is people going to the hospital
without being without paying for it is
about 45 billion dollars a year we have
a 2.5 trillion dollar health sector so
basically we're saying we have to turn
the whole health sector over to
government because of this problem that
really can be dealt with in a much
different way with helping people
lower-income people purchase health
insurance it's more affordable that's
the wrong what uh what does Obamacare
mean for small businesses in particular
small businesses I think are really on
the firing line if they grow beyond 50
employees then they are subject to all
the rules and regulations is an
avalanche of rules and regulations in
Obamacare they not only have to provide
health insurance that government defines
or they pay a fine and a penalty but
they also have to know the household
income of their employees not just what
they're paying above what the household
income is so they can avoid even bigger
federal funds and there are just I mean
that the rules and regulations in the
mandates we see already in Massachusetts
they say not only is it the cost of
health insurance but the paperwork in
the bureaucracy but now everybody
supporters of the Massachusetts health
care reform bill that I guess Mitt
Romney helped Midwife they say but look
we've got really high rates of coverage
so it all balances out because taxpayers
are paying for so much of it the great
majority of the people who've gotten
health insurance coverage by the way
Massachusetts first started out with a
pretty high rate of coverage so the
additional ones primarily because I've
been subsidized either through Medicaid
or through the new health insurance
exchanges and taxpayer subsidized
coverage the rest of them have gotten
covers for employers who are trying to
avoid federal penalties so it's been
done but through onerous federal require
what is requirements what is the what do
you think is the long-term effect on
innovation of the health care reform
bill
this is going to kill innovation instead
of trying to figure out how to provide
care faster better cheaper and we were
on a trajectory just ready for that to
begin to take hold that unless the last
decade but now everybody is looking over
their shoulder and trying to figure out
how do I comply with this new Federal
Rule this new regulation we already have
thousands of pages of regulations that
have come down as a result of the
passage of this law a year and almost
year and a half ago and it's it is
everybody is figuring out how do I
comply with this new federal rule rule
not how do I provide care better faster
and cheaper and make it more attractive
what is there any country or state in
the United States that has gotten health
care policy right and if so what are
they doing that we should be emulating I
know there's a lot of talk about well
surely there's Switzerland is doing it
better maybe the Netherlands we have to
get it right in America we have
basically every health care system you
could think of right here in America we
have the Veterans Administration which
is government employed doctors
government-owned hospitals we have
Medicare which works more like the
Canadian system where the government
pays private providers what we have to
do is is realize that we've got to show
the rest of the world the right way
we've got to show the rest of the world
which what's that's working yeah okay so
I mean hat what is the best way to bring
markets into the provision of healthcare
to empower consumers and we actually see
that these socialized systems in Europe
have gone so far toward government
control that they're realizing oh my
goodness that doesn't work we have to
figure out how to get doctors and
patients more engaged that's what we
need to do is show how you do that we've
already started with health savings
accounts with health reimbursement
arrangement what's the biggest stumbling
block I mean there's politicians who won
one thing but then do insurance
companies actually want patients to be
empowered do doctors
do patients I mean do patients want to
be paying out of their own pocket
directly they just don't want to pan
over on their own pocket but if we have
more transparency and they realize how
much they are paying for governor taxes
through government programs for their
own health insurance and lost wages plus
their own out-of-pocket costs allow them
to see that that money to give them more
choices in the marketplace the
marketplace is not responded consumers
its responding to big purchasers large
employers states the federal government
if we get employees and consumers
engaged then they're going to be able to
force the market to respond to the kind
of choices they want well thank you very
much we've been talking with grace
murray turner president of the gallon
institute and one of the authors of the
recent book why obamacare is wrong for
America grace Murray thanks for talking
to us the painting for reason TV I'm
Nicholas